hello
my name is carolyn luger i'm a
structural biologist at the university
of colorado at boulder
and an investigator for the howard
hughes medical institute and today i
want to tell you
a couple about a couple of key
experiments that enabled a breakthrough
in our
decade long efforts to determine the
three-dimensional structure
of the nucleosome but before i do this i
want to highlight the importance of this
problem at that time
the human genome is over 2 meters in
length
and has to fit into nucleus that's about
5 microns in size
a good analogy for this would be if you
had to fit
a human hair that is 10 miles long into
a golf ball
and you now imagine that you have to
take that hair and split it into two
during a process called dna replication
or imagine you have to find certain bits
of information
on that piece of hair all the while
leaving the hair
in the golf ball and avoiding tangles or
knots
a good analogy for using a dna as an
informational molecule is a cassette
tape that was used in prehistoric times
by humans
to record music and play music
just like the cassette tape human genome
packaging
poses many challenges we have to package
the information in a very confined space
we have to protect it from physical
damages and tangles
we have to regulate access to the stored
information so you need to find
your favorite abba song on your tape you
need to be able to tag that somehow and
find it rapidly
and we also have to accurately and
rapidly replicate the information that
is encoded on the tape let's say you
want to share that tape with your
friends
early views of human genome packaging
came from
taking chromosomes out of cells and
spreading them
very very thinly on electron microsc
microscopy grids this revealed that
the fundamental organizing unit of
chromatin
are spherical about 10 nanometer size
particles
these can then separate it out from
from from the chromosome by using an
enzyme called micrococcal nuclease this
enzyme cuts
unprotected dna but it will not cut the
particles themselves
and then further analyses of these
particles revealed that they're composed
of dna
roughly 150 base pairs of dna and four
to five
small very basic histone proteins
efforts were undertaken to determine the
structure of the nucleosome
by x-ray crystallography which was the
method of choice
in the 20th century this method entails
taking your molecule that you're
interested in and convincing it to form
ordered crystals you do this by uh
subtly changing the solvent conditions
around the molecule to
molecules to convince them to aggregate
with each other in an ordered manner
to form these beautiful structures here
shown in this green droplet
these crystals are about 100 to 500
micrometers in size so they're very very
small
so you use a microscope to fish them out
with a tiny little loop
it's almost like a spoon to mount them
in this crystal loop
this loop is then immersed in liquid
nitrogen to
rapidly vitrify the solvent around it
and is then mounted on a goniometer head
to be to be illuminated by x-rays
the electrons in our molecule will
diffract the x-rays and those diffracted
x-rays are collected
on either film or in later times by
electronic media
and it is this diffraction pattern that
then through a series of quite
complicated mathematical
operations that i will not go into will
then give rise to
what we call the electron density map
and this electron density map is then
used to build your macromolecule
which then allows you to identify the
location of every atom with respect to
every
other atom now you hear
crystallographers talking a lot about
high resolution high resolution is
really needed to understand
function what does that mean imagine
you're an alien and you're trying to
figure out
the function of a human hand imagine now
all you
all the only information that you have
is a is a mitten you find a mitten on
the road
and from that you conclude that humans
have a large
paddle-like protrusion and a smaller
protrusion
and this constitutes the human hand now
imagine that you're finding a ski mitten
you're getting quite a lot of more
resolution you now know that
humans have five fingers but it's still
quite limited
in the details that you can observe
the highest resolution structure you
would obtain from a latex glove
and there you can figure out details in
the finger joints and you could
begin to understand how the human hand
functions
this also illustrates a major problem
that we have in crystallography
because the images that we obtain the
structures that we obtain
are static images and from static images
it's sometimes hard to understand
functions and that's why
crystallographers and other structural
biologists always use orthogonal
approaches
to to obtain different states of the
molecule in question so that we can
interpolate
between those different states to see
how they get from here to there
and we also use additional methods to
observe these machines and molecules
in the act of doing their job
now back to resolution what determines
the resolution
in a crystal it is determined by order
a single crystal is contained is is
composed of
billions and billions of macromolecules
in the ideal case
all macromolecules would look the same
as seen in the example to the left side
we have all of our macromolecules very
happy and smiling
and so the average structure that we get
from that crystal lattice
would be a smiley and this would be a
very high resolution structure
in contrast if some of our
macromolecules are not happy
they're frownies they're incorporated
into the crystals and what we get from
these crystals is a composite of smileys
and frownies and so we really have a
hard time
to determine what their facial
expression is and this is what
would constitute a low resolution
structure
now back to nucleosomes the way
nucleosomes were
isolated in previous days and
were by isolating chromatin
from natural sources from chicken blood
or calf thymus
and by cutting out nucleosomes with
micrococcal nucleus
and using those for crystallization now
this posed a problem because by
definition the dna sequence of every
single nucleosome would be different
because we sample the entire genome
the dna length would also be subtly
different because the enzyme isn't that
accurate in
chewing back all the way and the histone
components the protein components are
also
highly variable because they exist in
many flavors
these many flavors have very very
important biological implications
but as far as crystallography goes they
really represent a big problem because
they preclude the formation of highly
diffracting crystals because the
material
is just simply too heterogeneous
and so this could be this should come as
no surprise that the first
efforts to determine the seven and to
determine the structure of the
nucleosome were limited to seven
angstroms so this would be the
equivalent of a mitten
and and we really couldn't see a lot of
detail from these structures but
we could discern that the dna was
wrapped around the outside of the
protein the protein constituted
a a dense core and we could discern the
superhelical path of the dna around the
outside of the cylinder
details were not distinguishable we
this structure did not allow us to
determine how the histones
hold to the dna and how they afford this
quite
profound distortion i should also point
out that
these low resolution structures more
than anything else rely on orthogonal
methods to verify the conclusions that
we draw from them
and in this particular case very
beautiful cross-linking data
from the mirza bekov lab really helped
us
to verify that this structure was
was true now how do we get to high
resolution how do we get from these
diffraction patterns that have very only
very few diffraction spots
to these beautiful starry night like
looking diffraction patterns
where we have lots of information and as
we as we say they refract to very high
resolution
there's three fundamental improvements
that had to be made
first and most importantly sample
homogeneity so we had to convince our
nucleosomes all to be happy and smiley
and this proved to be the most time
consuming and most difficult aspect of
this project
the second was that we had to find a way
to determine the phases
and that was not a trivial matter and
this is not something i will go into in
great detail
and third we needed access to stronger
x-ray beams
and it was very fortuitous that at that
time uh
third-generation synchrotrons were
developed that allowed us
that that produced very hard x-rays that
were required for this
project so how do we get to
uh greater sample homogeneity obviously
cutting nucleosomes out from
native tissues did not work so we had to
individually express every single
histone in bacteria
we then had to refold those histones to
form what we call a histon octamer just
a protein component of the nucleosome we
then had to find a dna sequence that was
uniquely suited to position nucleosomes
and to form nucleosomes
and we had to prep prepare vast amounts
of that dna and that was
in and of itself a major undertaking and
involved a lot of phenol extraction
um and not a lot of fun i should say
you then combine those two components
and i had to develop methods
to form the nucleosomes in
in vitro uh once i've done that i had to
convince myself and others that these
nucleosomes that i made
from scratch from bottom up from their
basic components
are exactly the same just better
than the native nucleosomes that we
would isolate from tissues
and that required uh quite a long uh
long effort
uh in in an effort in biochemistry and
other approaches
but finally we had nucleosomes that had
were unique with dna
sequence and length they had highly
uniform histones
and furthermore this approach allowed us
to introduce mutants into the histones
and this proved to be essential
for our efforts to determine the phase
problem
so all is well everybody is happy we
should be well on our way to determine a
high resolution structure
but of course this was not so as science
goes two steps forward
three steps back the crystals that we
obtained from this allegedly much
better material were actually much worse
they diffracted badly
sometimes they didn't crystallize at all
we got thin window panes that were
really not easy to mount
at all and so it seemed like all our
efforts were for naught
and so this was really a low point in
this whole effort and
i really we really had to dig ourselves
out from this hole i should point out
that the material that we put into these
crystals
when we analyze them on native gel
electrophoresis
looks kind of fuzzy and that's just how
they look like
but in order to find out why these
crystals all of a sudden were so
um ill-behaved and didn't produce uh
didn't didn't didn't diffract as well
i had to figure out what was
incorporated into the crystal
maybe something had to happen in that
long time where they refused to
crystallize
for them uh so that they could be
converted into a form that allowed them
to crystallize
so one way to do this is you just take
your hard-earned crystals and you
dissolve them
and you analyze in my gel and much to my
surprise i found that
rather than being fuzzy like the input
material
these crystals were actually the
contents of the crystals was actually a
very nice
crisp and uh tight band so this was
really weird
what happens there's two possibilities
formal possibilities in one possibility
we have a mixture of smileys and
frownies and only the smileys make it
into the crystal so when i dissolve
my crystal i can only see the nice tight
band composed of smileys
and the frownies would still be in what
we call the mother liquor
this is the liquor surrounding our
crystal in the second possibility
it could be that these two forms are
interchangeable or in equilibrium
and it could be that only our smileys
are incorporated into the crystals and
thereby
shifting the equilibrium pulling the
frownies over to the smileys
in this case i would have smileys in my
crystals
and nothing in the mother liquor so this
is a very easy hypothesis to test
and uh to our delight we saw that there
was really nothing left in the mother
liquor
and so this really means that this
hypothesis was correct
and now we had to find a way to convince
all of our frownies to be converted into
smileys
and that would really solve all of our
problems and allow us to move
ahead in our efforts to determine the
structure
so what are the possible reasons for
uh this sample heterogeneity
we know that our histones are uniform we
know our dna is uniform so the only
variable that was left was the position
of the dna on the histone optima
and this is illustrated by this little
yarn spool here with a white dna wrapped
around it
in the top example the dna is positioned
centrally and nice and tightly tucked in
in the bottom example i tucked on the
left hand side of my yar of my of my dna
and pulled it off a little bit this
leaves a little bit more of the yarn
spool
exposed and leaves some of the dna
sticking out
and indeed this is what we what we
believe has happened
uh this is shown in this cartoon uh
underneath the gel here
the three bands we believe uh are um
constitute the central centrally
positioned nucleosome that would be
the most fast moving because it's the
most compact
and then we'd have two nucleosome
species that have dna hanging out either
on the left side or on the right side at
different
angles and that would change her
electrophoretic behavior
and that thus would result in those
three bands so
how could we convince these two top
species to move to the centrally
positioned species
now we surmise that the centrally
positioned species would be the
thermodynamically most stable because
most of the dna is bound tightly and so
this would be a more stable situation
than having dna kind of flopping off the
side and so
uh we figured that a simple heating step
could actually do the job of converting
these species into each other
and much to our surprise just
introducing a little bit of thermal
energy in
heating our samples at 37 degrees for
half an hour
actually did the job and we now got
beautifully homogeneous particles
that actually gave rise to beautiful
crystals
and what was even better these crystals
diffracted to very high resolution
giving rise to these diffraction
patterns that still
i get goosebumps when i see them just
because they're so
nice to look at now you think you're
done right
but you're really not done structural
biology is an endurance sport
maybe like a triathlon uh so we've
solved the first
uh we solved the first problem the
structural homogeneity we've obtained
well diffracting crystals
now we have to solve the phase problem
without going into detail the phase
problem to solve this problem
involved me making about 25 or 30
mutants
in histones isolating each of these
mutants
in independently making 25 different
flavors of nucleosomes
and collecting data on these nucleosomes
so that we could obtain heavy atom
derivatives
and the third hurdle that we had to
overcome was uh using a high-energy
x-ray source these are very weakly
diffracting crystals and they require
what we call very hard x-rays
so that we could get enough intensity
from our diffracted crystals
and luckily the third generation
synchrotrons were under construction and
were becoming operational just at that
time
and synchrotrons are large particle
accelerators they're about two
kilometers in diameter
this is the one in grenoble the esrf we
were among the first users
and rumors have it that the first users
used their
waiting time while the samples were
exposed to
play squash in empty hutches and use the
smooth concrete floors
for rollerblading i would not know
anything about these rumors
so i will deny all all accounts of this
that's all i'll say about it so now
remember what the
the result that we get from diffraction
experiments
is not the structure itself it is
actually the electron density
the electron density without a model
built into it tells us nothing
the electron dens so so then i had to
sit for about a year in a dark room
painstakingly and manually building
a three-dimensional structure into this
model now this was
really really difficult because we had
no idea where to start we had no idea
what the secondary structure of these
proteins was
we had no idea where the dna was this is
the raw data that we had and so this is
like a big three-dimensional puzzle
and only when all the parts are fitted
correctly you can account for all the
electron density
and so this is what the final product
then would look like
and this this required as i said about
one year of work
in a dark room uh in front of a computer
monitor
not a very social experience here's a
detailed
a detailed view of the same density
and you can see that now we can actually
obtain the orientation of the
main chain and of the side chains of the
protein and this allowed us
to really uh to to describe
how the dna is held so tightly by the
histones how the histones interact with
each other
and this gives that give rise to this
iconic picture here of the
final nucleosome structure two different
orientation that now graces mouse pads
and textbooks and t-shirts
and it's just generally very very pretty
to look
at like all scientific endeavors
uh this particular uh
project uh took very many years
and it was a huge group effort and
couldn't have been done without my
colleagues at the eth
zurich with the guidance of tim richmond
you